enrique casalino merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors quelles
sont les hypothèses aujourd'hui qui
pourrait expliquer que ces personnes
infectées puisse re développer des
symptômes des semaines après leur
contamination au cours de beaucoup
d'infections virales
ça a été rapporté des syndromes de
fatigue une persistance de certains
symptômes et les miens gilles les
douleurs dans les muscles les douleurs
dans les articulations une grande
fatigue sont des symptômes fréquents
dans ce contexte c'est tout ce sont des
symptômes cantons et communes
connaissons assez bien au cours d'
infections virales comme par exemple
l'herpès le zostères au cours d'
infections virales chez l'adulte
par exemple si un adulte attrape une
varicelle on peut avoir des symptômes
qui persistent ça a été rapporté à une
époque on appelait ça le yuppie syndrome
le syndrome de fatigue chronique il ya
eu beaucoup de non ça ne veut pas dire
forcément que le virus est toujours
présent pour votre organisme
ça veut dire qu'il ya une perturbation
de la physiologie normal de votre
organisme et que ça nécessite un temps
plus ou moins prolongée de plusieurs
semaines voire parfois plusieurs mois
pour récupérer complètement
il avait une grosse crainte qu'ils
étaient pour nous médecins que les
patients qui avaient été sévèrement
atteints par exemple en réanimation
puisse garder des séquelles très lourde
de la fonction pulmonaire
parce que nous avions vu que dans l'aîné
crop soit dans l'est les autopsies qui
avait été faite au patient ou
malheureusement décédées
il y avait des lésions très sévère et on
pouvait craindre des fibroses de ce côté
là ne sont plutôt rassurés nous ne
voyons pas des grandes détresses
respiratoires persistante
il ya plutôt une bonne récupération de
la fonction pulmonaire
de ce côté là c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle c'est le sentiment que nous
avons actuellement
il va y avoir des enquêtes quand même
pour confirmer ces hypothèses et je
trouve très intéressant qui est des
équipes phase des travaux pour essayer
de comprendre quelle est la
physiopathologie
dix de ces symptômes persistants des
symptômes généraux par opa de les
atteintes pulmonaires pas des choses qui
auront une gravité ou un risque vital
pour les patients mais qu'effectivement
peuvent compromettre la capacité de
travail de certains patients donc si on
vous comprend
ces personnes finalement ne sont plus
contagieuse puisque le virus n'agit plus
dans leur corps c'est ça que vous nous
expliquiez c'est ça paraît pour le
moment être là les éléments que nous
avons aujourd'hui mais vous savez avec
cette maladie on découvre tous les jours
des nouvelles facettes
je fais confiance à l'équipe qui va
mettre en place ce travail pour savoir
exactement si la maladie est liée à une
persistance virale à une hyper
activation du système immunitaire comme
on peut le voir dans d'autres maladies
une absence d'une réaction adéquate du
système immunitaire à l'infection
il va y avoir peut-être un mélange
toutes ces hypothèses et ça va être très
intéressant ça va nous permettre
peut-être de mieux comprendre le
mécanisme de ces symptômes persistants
dans d'autres pathologies que le coc
vide donc la science avance en ordre de
bataille sur des champs différents mais
l'intérêt de découvrir exactement des
mécanismes et de proposer de nouvelles
options thérapeutiques et commun et je
suis certain qu'avec des protocoles
comme celui qui a été proposé nous
pourrons mieux répondre aux qu'ovide et
peut-être à d'autres infections virales
ou d'autres syndromes post viraux qui
peuvent avoir des répercussions
importantes chez beaucoup de nos
concitoyens et dans la population
mondiale
alors on observe également que ce sont
des quadragénaires souvent des femmes
qui sont touchées par ces symptômes
plusieurs semaines après le début de la
maladie est-ce que là encore ça nous
apprend quelque chose oui c'est très
intéressante vous savez qu'il ya eu un
gros débat sur les risques accrus des
hommes à faire certaines manifestations
avec le co vivre
je vais vous donner une anecdote lorsque
les syndromes de youppi syndrome c'est à
dire d'un syndrome de fatigue chronique
avait été rapportée aux états unis il ya
plus de trente ans on décrivait que ça
touche essentiellement des personnes qui
était énormément investis dans leur
travail
énormément présente dans leur travail
avec une énorme pression rigueur dans
leur travail
ce qui montre bien contre le côté
humanitaire le côté somatiques organique
et le côté psychologique
il y a des liens très forts et que nous
ne pouvons pas forcément les démêlés
nous savons qu'il ya des interactions
importante dans notre système
immunitaire psychisme des personnes
environnement et que tout ceci va jouer
un rôle et que c'est intéressant de voir
pourquoi ce sont plutôt des personnes
âgées
quelle est leur contexte socio
professionnelles quel est leur niveau
d'investissement et essayer d'explorer
toutes ces pistes se sont sûrement des
travaux extrêmement intéressant et très
riche d'enseignements merci beaucoup
emeric et casalino d'avoir partagé votre
expertise rappelle que vous êtes chef
des urgences à l'hôpital bichat